séquence une plan 2 prise 2 silence ça
tourne dans cet appartement une équipe
d'une dizaine de personnes tous
bénévoles et tous motivés en un weekend
seulement ils doivent réaliser un
courtmétrage les directives ont été
données le vendredi soir et le dimanche
soir tout doit être livré tout est
compliqué c'est un challenge en fait
déjà l'organisation trouver une équipe
avec des gens des techniciens des
comédiens qui soient disponi sans savoir
vraiment ce qu'ils vont faire parce
qu'on sera dernier moment en fait en
fonction du tirage en fonction du
scénario donc déjà l'organisation et
puis écréer un scénario avoir de
l'inspiration sur le moment faut faut
que ça vienne très vite faut que tout
Vienne très vite il y a très peu de
répétition pour cette équipe ce fut
écriture le vendredi tournage le samedi
et montage le dimanche dans les critères
imposés le genre cinématographique un
personnage un objet mais aussi des
répliques pas facile donc de composer
avec tout cela quant au scénario du film
nous aurons bien essayer mais aucune
information sur le script nous a été
donnée confidentialité oblig jusqu'à la
projection nous n'avons même pas eu le
droit de filmer la scène alors
l'histoire c'est difficile on est tombé
sur le genre film noir et on a eu
beaucoup de chance parce que c'est notre
genre de prédilection et puis ben on
s'est lâché donc comment pourra raconter
ça je peux pas la raconter je peux juste
dire que c'est une histoire qui est très
très
Glo noir les personnages sont barrés
barré il peut l'être rodolp Coutu acteur
bien connu à tour et qui s'est livré à
cet exercice ce soir tout sera joué
l'équipe saura enfin si le film ira à
Hollywood concourir pour la finale
internationale